all right so thank you for the
invitation it's really exciting to take
part of my afternoon to come over here
and talk to you all about some of the
work that we're doing as Ava said I
co-lead a couple of things at Google one
is this team called the big picture
group and a lot of our work centers
around data visualization in the last
three years or so it's been very much
focused on data visualization for a
machine-learning so you'll get to hear a
lot about what we do today I also could
lead the pair initiative which is stands
for people plus AI research and there we
have a bunch of different kinds of
things that we do as part of this
initiative we produce open source
software hopefully some of which you are
familiar with tensorflow is anyone
tensorflow yes yes yes I'm seeing some
noddings here we also put out
educational materials so some of this
actually starts to overlap with the data
visualization for machine learning we've
noticed that even as we at Google try to
retrain our own engineering workforce to
use machine learning it turns out that
if you have simulations and data
visualization front ends to play with
some of these systems you just speed up
learning by like a factor of 10 instead
of going back to the command line to
learn some of the basics so we can talk
a little bit about that today as well
all right so the first thing kind of
let's start at the beginning with the
data right why might you want to
visualize your training data and what's
special about your training data one of
the things that we started saying at
Google is that whenever you start
working with machine learning and you
you look at your results and maybe your
results are not coming out as strongly
as you would wish there is this innate
intuition or this you're like itching to
debug you're a machine learning model
right one of the
things we always say is before you even
debug your model debug your data and
that becomes it's it's incredibly
important I'm sure you're talking about
a lot of that here in the class as well
problem is we don't have good tools to
do that today so we're starting to build
us at Google and other places
everybody's starting to think about what
might be interesting tools for you to
start to debug your training data the
data that your system is going to rely
on so we started to approach this from a
data visualization perspective so what I
have here is a screenshot of the CFR ten
data set everybody familiar with that
data set very simple data set of images
ten classes that's all and so what I'm
going to demo for you right now is a
visualization we created it's called
facets and facets is a visualization
right now I'm visualizing Safari ten and
all I'm doing as you can tell is I'm
just looking at all the pictures these
are not all it's it's a sample of cifra
ten of the pictures in each class and I
can very easily zoom in and I can see
what the pictures look like I can zoom
out and even as simple as this is it
already starts to give me a window into
what's happening with my data one of the
things I can see right away is that the
heels are different right something you
may expect so the the top row here is
airplane and you can see that it has a
ton more blue than say bird or a cat or
deer and so this ship that may be
expected right because I take pictures
of airplanes against the sky and I take
pictures of ships against the water okay
but then I can start to play some
interesting games I can say show me the
same data set within each category but
now I want you to arrange this in terms
of hue distribution okay so now I can
start to see okay
these are little histograms of my
pictures per category per hue and voila
what are the bluest of the blue
airplanes or there might be some
interesting blue birds here okay
these are also against the sky that's
interesting let me see you I have some
Reds on airplanes okay interesting just
a very easy organic way to start looking
at my data I can also look for things
like okay what are the classes of in my
data set that have the the most if you
will kind of equal distribution of hues
you get to things like ships and trucks
and and so forth and you have these
bulges of kind of earthy tones for the
animals right which makes sense I can
also start playing other games so I can
come here and say okay now give me a
confusion matrix of my data and again
the confusion matrix is going to pair
each one of these rows is what the
system thinks my image is versus each
one of the columns is what the humans
have hand labeled my image to be so the
good news to me is that right away I can
see that the diagonal is the most
populated set of cells that's good
because that's where my system and the
humans agree right and another
interesting thing I can see here right
away is that I have a couple of cells
that are highly populated I have this
cell here ton of pictures and I have
this other cell here ton of pictures and
sure enough these are my system is
getting confused between dogs and cats
okay so that already might start to give
me some hints as to what I might want to
debug about my system maybe I need to
give it more images of cats and dogs so
it does better on those classes now keep
this in mind this is C far 10 this is
kind of a hello world data set of
machine learning everybody looks at this
data set
everybody benchmarks against this data
set it's been looked at by thousands of
people right so we started visualizing
this and we're like oh okay so my system
is very sure that these are cat these
are not cats so let's see what the cats
are that my system is very short are not
cats interesting okay so I can see how
like this guy here has a lot big ears
maybe it's getting confused about that
all right but then we started seeing
some interesting things I challenge you
to find something in the bottom rows
that is indeed not a cat anyone a frog
yes look at this this was hand labelled
cat but my system is a hundred percent
sure it's a frog and I have to give it
to it I think it's a frog I don't think
it's a cat at all but why does that
matter it matters because just by giving
you the ability to look at your data you
can start to see actual mistakes in your
data right and again this is a data set
that thousands of researchers and
practitioners use and benchmark again
benchmark against and nobody knew that
there were a couple of mistakes there
interesting things right so again just
creating a the ability to look at your
data very easily can buy you can get rid
of a lot of headache for you so that's
that's facets and we open sourced facets
so facets is available for anyone to use
and it's been downloaded a bunch of
times you don't have to use it for
machine learning it's a visualization
tool for any kind of faceted data set so
you can use it for anything you want and
here at MIT people have started using it
so joy for instance at the Media Lab was
using facets to look at racial bias
racial and gender bias in facial
recognition
facial recognition systems from industry
and she was using the visualization to
make the point that
the category of women of color where the
was the category that these system would
consistently do worse at alright I'm
gonna I'm if I have time I'm gonna come
back to the what if tool the only thing
I'll say about this tool is that it's
another open-source tool that we created
that allows you to probe a machine
learning model as a black box and to
probe for things like machine learning
fairness different concepts of ML
fairness if we have time we'll come back
to this alright so we just talked about
the importance of looking at your data
now let's talk a little bit about what
can you learn when you're looking at
your model sort of how is your model
understanding the world how is it making
sense of very very high dimensional data
so I'm gonna walk you through a very
quick exercise in high dimensionality so
a warm-up exercise M nest yes M nest
everybody familiar with omnis
data set of machine learning and i'm
going i'm going to start pulling us over
to the world of visualization again so
think about each one of these images as
a very high dimensional vector how might
I think about that all I'm going to do
is I'm going to count the pixels and
depending on the color of the pixel I'm
gonna give it a value from zero to one
one if it's all white zero if it's black
something in the middle if it's a gray I
end up with a vector boom i transformed
an image into math that's great
now I have a great way to compare these
images alright so then we created a
visualization to actually look at this
so this is another tool that's open
sourced by pear and this is called the
embedding projector and now what we're
doing here we're looking at M mist in
high dimensional space okay so this is a
3d projection of of the Emnes
numbers okay all I did here since I have
ground truth I colored the numbers by
the ground truth okay and the projection
I'm using here is T's me it's a
nonlinear projection it does really well
in keeping track of local clusters it
doesn't do very well at all in
understanding the global structure of
things but locally it's very good so
what do we have here the good news is
that we have clusters that's a good
starting point and we have space between
clusters so that's really good because
it tells me that somehow these
categories are being pulled apart from
each other we also have so let's start
playing with this tool
it lets me rotate in many different ways
I can zoom in and out to look more
carefully at things I can also click on
things so basically just so you know
what's going on here I'm setting up a
demo using the same tool that shows you
how a visualization like this can work
in a real system in a large system the
system I was showing you before the the
data was showing you before it was
eminent
right very easy toy example what I'm
showing you now and this is it's taking
its time to get to the T Snee projection
it's calculating T's needs calculating
all the clusters in this data set and I
want to be able to interact with it
that's why I'm taking my time and I'll
talk to you while this is working in the
background okay so we're gonna let this
do its thing it's gonna run in the
background I'm gonna try to get it not
to distract us completely meanwhile
let's talk about interpretability in a
real world scenario so a couple years
ago Google came out with something
called a multilingual neural net
Translate system what what does that
mean
it means that up until that moment
whenever you wanted to use neural nets
to translate between two languages you
had to train a model on a pair of
languages so I trained a model between
English and French French English I
trained a different model for English
and Japanese Japanese English okay so it
was all based on pairs for the first
time Google came up with an architecture
they'll let you ingest multiple
languages and translate high-quality
translations into multiple languages
okay and that was that was a revelation
it was it was quite a feat and so that's
called the multilingual translation
models there's another thing that was
interesting in what these systems were
doing somehow they were able to do what
we call zero shot translation okay and
so what that means is that imagine I
have a system that is that is ingesting
a bunch of sentences that translate
between English and Japanese Japanese in
English and it's also ingesting a bunch
of sentences that translate between
glish and Korea and back and forth okay
somehow this system was able to also do
Japanese to Korean and Korean to
Japanese without ever having seen a
single example of a sentence that goes
straight from one to the next okay from
Japanese to Korean so one of the
challenges one of the big unknowns is
that the people building these systems
they weren't sure how is the system
being able to do this with high quality
translation high quality translation is
extremely hard to get is extremely
announced and so how is it doing that
oh this was the data that we decided to
visualize to actually start answering
that question okay it turns out that
between the encoder and the decoder
there is an attention vector in the
middle
and this is the data that we were that
we were going to visualize all right the
question in these researchers Minds
these are the people who were building
the Translate system was imagine I have
space with multiple languages an
embedding space a very high dimensional
space of language what were these
multilingual systems doing were they
doing something like what's here on the
Left where they would resolve the space
by keeping all the English in one corner
keeping all the Japanese on the other
corner and keeping all the Korean in
another corner and then just mapping
between these spaces for translations or
where's the system doing something more
like what you see on the right where
it's way more messy but they're bringing
together these multiple languages okay
and so this why does this matter why
does it matter if it's one way or
another way it matters because if what
the system was doing was mixing up the
different languages in the same high
dimensional space it had a very specific
implication which meant it the system
didn't care as much that one string said
for instance home and another string
said cazza it knew that these two
strings had the same semantic meaning so
if it was co-locating these very
different strings from very different
languages in the same high dimensional
space it meant that it was paying
attention to actual the semantics the
actual meaning of the words and that
matters because that then tells us that
these are the first indications of a
universal language okay and so but we
had no way of knowing so we decided to
visualize and how might we visualize
this imagine I have a sentence that says
something like the stratosphere extends
from 10 kilometers to 50 kilometers in
altitude
what does that look like in high
dimensional space it looks like a bunch
of points where some points are going to
be closer together like the 10 and the
15 maybe because they're both numbers
okay so again location has a specific
meaning here in high dimensional space
and then what we do with the
visualization is we connect these dots
and so that is my sentence in high
dimensional space it's the path of my
sentence okay so now I have my sentence
in English what does this look like when
I have to set to when I have a
translation does it look like this where
I have my English sentence in one corner
and I have the Portuguese version of
that sentence on another corner or does
it look more like something like this
okay and so this is what we're trying to
find out
so the visualization for this let me see
is actually this here so what I'm
showing here again we're back in the
embedding projector and I'm visualizing
a multi-dimensional tea lingual system
that takes in English Japanese and
Korean I am coloring each one of those
languages by a different color so
English is blue Korean is red Japanese
is yellow okay my question to you is as
messy as this looks do you see a big
neighborhood of red and a big
neighborhood of blue and a big
neighborhood of yellow no right so that
right there was our very first
indication that something really
interesting was happening because we
started to see clusters that had the
three colors together okay and so the
thing that I was hoping to show you but
I don't know that I'm gonna be able to
show you let me see if I can oh maybe
maybe I'll show you like this
so if I do a search for
stratosphere well it it just did a bunch
of stuff here that is not helpful
ah I'm gonna try to drag it all the way
here do you see this little cluster here
the stratosphere with the altitude
between 10 and 50 kilometers okay ignore
all of this junk here this is not
supposed to be there but this is what I
care about if I look at this cluster
okay and I look at the nearest neighbors
these are the nearest neighbors here
that I'm mousing over the three
languages are here okay and my nearest
neighbors for that ain't for that
sentence in English both in Japanese and
in Korea are all in that cluster alright
so that in fact did you see I just
clicked out and you see the cluster has
three colors here so that was our
indication that this was actually the
beginning of a universal language
this system was actually being able to
coalesce the three spaces of three
different languages in terms of semantic
meaning now keep this image in mind and
I want to show you a sister image of the
image a visualization of a sister system
this system here it's the same kind of
visualization but this is a system that
takes in English Portuguese and Spanish
okay what do you see that's different
here separated right I see a big
neighborhood of red there and so we saw
this and we're like wait wait wait a
second we thought there were indications
of a universal language going on what is
that doing there by itself so we did a
statistical analysis for quality of
translation and we found out that the
sentences in this cluster the
was being pulled apart they were the
translation translations were all bad
low-quality translations okay so what
does that tell us it tells us that the
geometry of the space matters that if
you have a multilingual system kind of
in the case Google had if your system
looks like this that's bad news that
means that your system is not being able
to cluster in the right way and it's
having difficulties and it's going to do
a bad job with translations
okay so again visualization here not
only to give you a sense of the
landscape of what's happening these
massively high dimensional spaces but
also giving you a clue of how to start
debugging your system maybe you need
more training data in in Portuguese
maybe it's something else but you have a
problem okay so this was really exciting
because it was the first time anyone
could see kind of like an MRI version of
this neuro net and the fact that it was
functioning at the super-high level it
was functioning for a language a couple
of other things I wanted to show the
same visualization can let us to
understand things about our own language
that I think are very interesting so
this is again the embedding projector
and you can one of the things I didn't
demo today
is not only do you have these
projections like T Snead that you just
saw or PCA you also can create custom
projections you can say let's look at
the English language so imagine each one
of those dots is a word in the English
language okay
and now what I want to understand is the
notion of biases in our language okay
you may be familiar with papers like
this one about word embeddings and the
fact that you can do you can do
calculations in
in the direction of certain vectors so
you can say oh look you know in word
embedding space if I take the direction
between China and Beijing if I take that
direction and I follow roughly that
direction from Russia I'm going to end
up in Moscow okay if I follow that
direction for Japan I'm going to end up
in Tokyo and so on and so forth so there
are these meaningful directions in
wording bedding spaces that are
incredibly powerful so now let's use
that to start visualizing language what
I did here is I went to the embedding
projector that you just saw and I looked
for the word book okay and then I
filtered all the words by the hundred
top nearest neighbors to book so I have
words like biography and publishing and
manuscript all the nearest neighbors to
book but then I said okay now I want to
see these words along the following
projection I want to give an axis that
goes from old to new so the closest the
more to the left of where it is the
closest to old it is so let's see some
of the words I have poem manuscript
author story okay closest to new here on
the right I have company publications
theory mind creation volume okay okay
interesting now let's look at a
different set of words my ex is now is
man to woman and my focal word my anchor
word is engineer and all of its nearest
neighbors so I can tell already the
engineer is closer to man than it is to
woman by the way the y-axis doesn't mean
anything it's random just pay attention
to the X location okay
so closer to man I have engineers
engineering electrical electronics I
have a really interesting word here at
the bottom but I can't look at the
bottom I can't point Michael Michael is
one of the top nearest neighbors to
engineer that's crazy okay and then
close to woman I have journalist lawyer
officer diplomat writer poet okay let's
keep going my new anchor word is math
between men and woman next to men
computational arithmetic flash
computation physics astronomical so
forth next to a woman
psychology instance procedural art
educational library and so forth I
changed my axes now it goes from
Christian to on the left to Jew on the
right and my anchor where it is moral so
close to Christian Christian beliefs
religion faith religious closest to Jew
intellectual psychological serious
educational sexual Liberty ethical so
forth okay why does this matter it
matters because it starts to it's to me
this is kind of like the cannery on the
mine about this is just language the
data set here remember we were talking
about training data be incredibly
important word to vac which is this data
set
it's from hundreds of thousands of
publications it's just how we use
language in the real world okay so when
you were training your machine learning
systems based on language one thing to
keep in mind is the fact that you're
training on a biased data set and so
being aware of these biases can actually
be incredibly important and hopefully
being able to use tools like
visualization tools starts to give you a
way of even becoming aware acknowledging
under
and trying hopefully trying to mitigate
some of these effects I think I'm gonna
stop here and open up for questions
thank you any questions
ah that's an awesome question if if if
you had a word that had multiple
meanings in say a projection like this
it would probably show up in the middle
which would not be very illuminating
another thing that happens on the
embedding projection projector is that
you may have a word that is very very
strongly so let's take let's talk about
a concrete example the word Bank okay
the word Bank can be a financial
institution it can also be a river bank
right if my corpus of data that I
trained on is on financial news there is
going to be a very high pole towards
financial institution vocabulary right
and I will see that bias in my data set
hopefully what also shows up if my data
set is broad enough is that when I
highlight that word in the visualization
here I was filtering but imagine I have
the entire language okay let's say I
highlight the word Bank
it definitely lights up all of the
financial institutional vocabulary
that's highly connected to that but it
also lights up stuff like River
elsewhere in the visualization and that
is one indication where you're like oh
interesting there are these disparate
very separate clusters here maybe
there's something there maybe that's one
indication that you have these multiple
words with multiple meanings
so part of what we were trying to
understand was what mode at all it was
in we had no clue we were literally like
if it separates that's fine if it
doesn't separate that's interesting
literally we were like just give me a
telescope so I can look into this world
and see what it looks like the system
was working really well so it was more
of a curiosity of trying to understand
how is it working so well what is it
doing that it can get to these very high
quality translations from no training
data on specific pairs right it was more
that kind of question than the oh we
think it should do this or we think it
should do that it was literally like
what is it even doing that it works this
way
once we got to that set of questions
another set of questions that came up
was like well here's a system that's not
working so well why is it not working so
well and so that was the point that I
was trying to make when I showed Olek
this system between English Japanese and
Korean that was working really well that
looked like this okay now let's look at
a system that was not working so well
and it's a sister system okay here's a
clue about why maybe it was not working
as well does that make sense yeah sure
in terms of biases oh yeah I think one
thing that would be wonderful
that I don't know that anyone has done
yet is exactly what I let me know if I'm
understanding your question correctly I
think it would be wonderful to compare
embedding spaces of different languages
right it could be that in English we
have a set of biases that maybe don't
exist in Turkish I don't know but and
even even trying to understand for
instance what are the nearest neighbors
of a given word in English versus
nearest neighbors of a given word in
French how much does that set of how do
those embedding spaces differ I think
that would be incredibly interesting one
specific if we're talking about
translation one very complex issue that
touches translation word embeddings and
and biases is what happens what used to
happen now Google started addressing
this what used to happen when you went
to Google Translate and you said
something about a doctor and a nurse the
doctor is coming and the nurse and the
nurse will see you okay so when you were
to translate between languages that have
gender like English two languages that
don't have gender like Turkish it turns
out that in so imagine it going the
other way around imagine I have that
sentence the doctor is coming to see you
in Turkish and I am translating that
into English on Google Translate Google
Translate would translate it into he's
coming the doctor is coming to see you
he will look at your exams there was an
assumption that it was a he
if the word been used was nurse there
would be an assumption in English that
the pronoun following nurse would be she
okay even though the original the source
language had no notion of gender
whatsoever attached to any of those
words right and so Google had to
actively proactively work out a solution
where it realizes it's coming from a non
gendered language to one that has biases
in terms of professions and gender and
give users a solution like oh the doctor
is coming to see you
he /she will talk to you next or
something like that so you yeah these
are the kinds of biases you want to be
aware of and try to mitigate work around
a very interesting point because part of
what we're trying to do is we're trying
to understand what is the intent on the
user side so as a user I want a
translation to my problem which is I see
a sentence in Turkish and I have no idea
what it means in English if all you're
giving me is the top hit from a
statistical distribution you're giving
me a very specific answer you're not
giving me all the possible answers to my
translation problem as a user as a user
it is important for me to know that the
translation to that sentence could be he
but it could be she right
or do I want a distribution do I want
you to decide for me what the
translation is again like if I am if I
don't know the language I'm translating
from right I want to understand what are
the possibilities in my own language I
can understand so that therein lies the
dilemma it really depends on what do you
think what do you think the user the
users intent is and how do you work with
that but yeah
to your point absolutely again we're
back to the fact that the data is skewed
absolutely it is skewed right and to
your point it reflects a certain reality
thank you